well we can't talk about Trump without
talking about Adam Schiff and Adam
Schiff went on The View and he talked to
Joy bather so do I even have to lead it
with anything other than that they're
going to be blocking Biden's agenda
investigating his family and his cabinet
Hunter Biden's laptop they promised to
kick you off the house intelligence
committee what are you going to do about
that
well you know in terms of my uh my
service on the intelligence committee
this was one of the promises I think
Kevin McCarthy gave one of the great
many that growing list to try to placate
the hardliners like Marjory Taylor green
and get their support
um but uh but you know there are much
bigger concerns frankly I have with what
they will do
Carol is McCarthy showing up on these
shows particularly The View which has
become a complete caricature of what
Barbara Walters who just passed away
wanted to create you know 20 years ago
is that just a perfect example of what
sort of the swamp and the Machine and
the monster is these people who lie
about everything never get fired never
get called out all of the stuff it just
endlessly happens over and over and
usually they actually just get
promotions out of it or or better TV
gigs so you said McCarthy I'm sure you
mean [ __ ] oh I'm sorry shift yeah so I
maybe I didn't maybe that that might
have been a very uh question got really
interesting with the McCartney although
that would be interesting right
right um
you know I
of course it is of course ship is just
part of the absolute swamp via swamp but
he he says that like MTG wants to get
rid of him
um and I want to know which Republican
wants to keep Schiff like who is the
Republican who is who would like to have
him stay on so the idea that that it's
some hardliners who are anti-himp like
no that's a pretty all all-around idea
that we all share
um that that shift is just the absolute
worst and that he's you know reduced to
talking on The View about his
um plans and how much he hates various
Republicans Buck do you think it's a
good idea so assuming that it is
McCarthy or one way or another the
Republicans are going to get this thing
and it's not going to be Hakeem Jeffries
do you like the idea of just opening up
investigations into everything do you
think that's what people want whether
it's covid or whether it's looking into
the January 6 commission or any of all
the nonsense they've put us through is
that the best use of their time or would
you rather them go in another Direction
it's the thing that they do that they
can do it's not going to make very much
difference
um the the Benghazi effect I think is
where this becomes most apparent uh the
Benghazi hearings look once Barack Obama
won re-election the idea that there was
going to be accountability for Benghazi
to anybody who understands the
bureaucracy I mean I come out of the CIA
right it was laughable it's just not
going to happen there's just no way
because what happens when you look at a
failure like that you have all these
different people who just point the
fingers at 100 other people and no one's
really responsible for anything right
the only accountability comes for the
person at the top whether State
Department or the president and that
didn't happen so it was great for people
to audition for cable news uh shows
after they finished their congressional
terms but it had no actual effect
whatsoever
um I think that you are likely to see
uh some of these investigation the the
one the one where I would say it's
different because we really do need the
information more information is on
anything coveted and vaccine related
um on on that data internally because
that fight as we all know is still going
on to convince more people of how wrong
the fauci Democrat side was on this and
also how dishonest they were so I'm in
favor of getting that information out
there if you'd like more sane takes on
our insane World check out our direct
message clips playlist and if you want
to watch more full episodes of our live
round tables watch our round tables
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell